grilling beef for hours
is part of argentina's tradition raul
vope
is proud of what his family has achieved
they're experts in preparing the
traditional asado or barbecue
the grilling method used by the gauchos
or skilled horsemen
who roamed argentina's pampa region in
the 18th and 19th centuries
[Music]
we are proud to say this is a restaurant
that feeds everyone all social classes
those who have money and those who don't
but things have changed
it's becoming more and more expensive
those who come have less money
the pandemic has forced restaurants like
this one to adapt
it's working at 30 percent of its
capacity
what complicates the situation even more
is that beef is becoming more expensive
in a country where people are used to
eating meat nearly every day
latest reports show that beef
consumption has dropped to an
all-time low or about 50 kilos a person
a year
half the amount consumed in the 1950s
one of the reason is a changing eating
habits but there is more
beef plays a crucial role in argentina's
culture this type
of asados are part of people's daily
life but in the past year the price of
beef has increased around 70
because of an inflation and an increase
of exports and that's why the government
is putting together a plan that aims to
reduce
the price of certain cuts due to rising
prices
cows were taken last year to graze land
instead of being fattened with corn
they slow down beef production and
reduce the supply
experts in the area fear government
intervention to control the prices
back in 2008 government restrictions to
prevent a rise in prices
ended with a loss of around 20 percent
of argentina's cattle herd
i think it's a political action trying
to reduce the price of beef
we export only three percent of what we
consume if the government tries to act
on the effect and not on the causes
which is the rise in prices of almost
everything in the country
patricia mori is a butcher who was
forced to adapt her shop
and sell other products she says the
increase in the price of beef
makes it difficult for her business to
thrive
we've had a 40 decrease in the sales of
beef
mostly because of price not everyone can
pay for beef
people were used to eating it all the
time but that's not the case now
we're selling chicken and other produce
so that we can get our sales up
beef consumption is a reflection of
argentina's economy
and that's one of the reasons why the
government wants to guarantee people
have access to it
but failed policies of the past may end
up hurting the sector
that has made argentinian beef famous
worldwide al jazeera buenos aires